this was the poll question from the
first two hours more surprised that the
cabs would beat lose to the Celtics or
the Warriors would lose to the Rockets
now we're talking about the entire
series how would you vote on that I'd be
more surprised if the Warriors lost the
Rockets just because I think Cleveland
Boston is more evenly matched it's not
by a lot but you know LeBron you just
finished the Cavs just finished
you know brooming the Raptors out but
you know a couple days before that they
were life and death the Indiana Pacers
that you haven't seen Golden State play
like that so I think that'd be more
surprised if the Warriors lost when the
series started it felt like the experts
where everybody was all in on Cavs and
Golden State do you think everybody's
still all in on the Cavs no and I don't
think people have been all in on the
Cavs for a while I know I haven't and I
think that opinions been been widespread
throughout throughout the league some
people will always believe that LeBron
is capable of carrying a team to the NBA
Finals I just didn't see it this year
too much inconsistency the absence of
Kyrie Irving was too significant you
know they've got a lot of flaws there
now I don't know what went on in Game
one
I mean LeBron he has this habit and it's
happened before it happened in Game one
of the Indiana series to just kind of
take Game one off and I find it
astonishing at times but that's just who
he is
he took Game one off against Boston he's
not going to do it in Game two
so what he looks like in Game two how he
comes out what his supporting cast does
playing off them this game to to me is
maybe the most interesting game of the
entire postseason and if Boston would
happen to win this one I don't think
that Cleveland comes back I don't I
think I think look I put it this way I
think it's more important for Boston to
win Game two that it is for Cleveland
because I think Cleveland can rally at
home to win through and you know win one
in Boston down the line for sexy at Game
seven if it comes to that
I think Boston badly needs these two
games if they win these two games I
think they could win the series in five
you know that I don't know if it's a
Carrick character trait or flaw or what
it says about LeBron that there is that
feeling sometimes that he'll just sort
of say all right
you know I'm resigned to the fact that
we're not going to win this game I don't
know that it's just a weird thing to
have for one of the greatest players of
all time he just you know it's funny
like you know they fall behind by 20 and
you get the sense watching the Brawn
play that LeBron knows he could probably
pull this game within single digits by
himself but you have to expend a lot of
energy through it so I think he kind of
made it felt to me anyway watching the
second half but he made a calculated
decision not to expend that energy not
to try to pull the game within seven
eight points and then you know just let
this game kind of slip away I mean it
it's an unbelievable risk and one thing
I think Boston's did really well in Game
one that they'll continue to do that I
didn't see a lot from again with Indiana
and certainly not with Toronto is that
they made LeBron work on the offensive
end or whether it was Jalen brown or
Tatum or Morris they went at LeBron if
he was guarding a rose here they can't
run here in motion they were not going
to allow LeBron just sit back and
quarterback the defense they were going
to make him play defense and if they
keep doing that they have the potential
to snap some of his energy they believe
in Boston that that may be the best
defensive strategy against LeBron is to
make him work hard on offense would you
rather have Jason Tatum's future or Ben
Simmons it's a good question one I've
thought about a lot and in the aftermath
of that that Philadelphia series I'm
gonna say Tatum because I don't think
that Simmons unless unless I see a
commitment from Simmons to change his
jump shot there's always gonna be some
kind of ceiling to him he's still gonna
make some great plays and if he does
develop that jump shot we can have a
different discussion but I really
believed in and and maybe it's not with
this incarnation of a Boston team
because I mean you saw those like the
quarter of a billion dollars in Talent
Boston has the back end of their bench
in Game one I mean
they're gonna have scores next year and
if Tatum's part of this group for the
next few years he's not gonna put up
great number but Tatum's down the line
is going to be have the capacity to be a
twenty eight to thirty eight per game
score I really believe that wait wait
wait watch up twenty eight to thirty
eight thirty thirty okay twenty eight to
thirty thirty volunteers remain okay
that know the thirty points per game
threshold is something that in the
modern NBA not a lot of players that
have kind of crashed through it but I
see that talent in Tatum I really do I
mean he's scoring right now Dan on skill
and length and a little bit of quickness
when Tatum develops his man strength in
any kind of modicum of a post game he's
gonna be special because he can't go
through guys right now he's got to go
around them he's got to go over them he
can't power through anybody over the
next couple of years when he's like the
tender age of 22 he's gonna be able to
start powering through players on a
regular basis and when he can do that
he's gonna be downright unstoppable on
that end would you rather have Ben
Simmons jumper or Lonzo balls I'd rather
watch the ball lots of food in but no
but you have you have Ben Simmons now
with that jumper of whatever it's gonna
turn out to be or Lonzo balls I'm taking
laws okay
because I don't broken no I mean did a
lot loseth probably heard this before
but laws the biggest problem is not
going to be his three-point shot I mean
it's just not it's his biggest problem
is gonna be when he's going what is it
left to right and he's pulling up from
the mid-range you know he's got that
extra hitch coming over you know good
defender is going to get in his face and
contest or block because of that but his
three-point shot is not a problem
I was wondering if you showed him Kevin
Durant's jumper and I pointed this out a
couple of times that Durant's jumper
starts on the left side of his head and
then yeah you know he then he brings it
over and puts it in there correctly now
he's seven feet tall with a wingspan of
seven six so he's got more room to
maneuver there you know Lonzo starts
more like a windshield wiper where he's
too far left to get it to where he needs
to when he has time to do it he's got
good rhythm there but I'm wondering if
you can fix that you know anywhere down
the road here for Lonzo ball
we know Ben Simmons need needs to have a
jumper he doesn't have one Lonzo needs
it feels like to shorten his up a little
bit you you can fix that
I would imagine though and I haven't
talked anybody the lakers about this
recently but i would imagine that's not
going to be a priority for them in the
offseason i mean as as long as it's
going in the lakers aren't going to have
a problem with him he got better
as the season went on more the point
with with a guy like with any young
player I mean these young guys then
every level they've ever played in
they've probably been the best player on
the floor going to a young player who's
been a star all his life and saying that
what you're doing is wrong
we're gonna fix it it's very hard to get
that young player to accept that to buy
into that a handful have done it and
Kawhi is the greatest example of it
because Kawhi came to San Antonio
overhauled his jump shot under chip
Engelland
and became one of the best jump shooters
in the NBA but getting a guy to really
do that what he doesn't believe that his
shot needs work you know Simmons a
different animal I mean we could see
Simmons shooting with a different hand
next year I mean that you know there
could be a lot that goes into the sim to
change in Simmons game but for Lonzo I
think it's gonna stay largely the same
before I let you go I know you saw Logan
chenko that fight
fill fill America in on just how big or
important this kid is he's he's probably
I mean Floyd Mayweather is the most
talented fighter I've ever seen but
defensively he's more defensive oriented
Vasili lomachenko is the most gifted
offensive fighter that I've ever seen he
can fight anywhere from 126 to 135
pounds he's got the best footwork you've
ever seen he's like a ballet dancer out
there with how well he can move with his
feet and what he did against the biggest
opponent of his career physically I mean
you know Horan Linares came into the
fight at about 140 145 pounds had about
10 pounds on him in that fight what he
did to him wearing him down
systematically if you ever get a chance
to watch him fight he's he's truly one
of the great fighters of
this generation maybe of all time who's
just getting a look because he spent
most of his career in the amateurs
winning gold medals yeah I saw
SportsCenter I had a feature on him and
you know his dad is his you know coach
and seems like he's he's got the it
factor there which boxing desperately
needs yeah it's just he's he's a you
know he's a little on the older side and
you know what boxing needs is you know
that younger fighter like Aloma chenko
who's english-speaking who could be the
face of it in the same way de la hoya
was when he came out of the Olympics in
1992 there there really isn't that guy
right now I mean there are some guys I
could name that are household names to
the boxing fans but you don't have a
golden boy a gold medal winning Oscar De
La Hoya that people can kind of connect
to MoMA chenko is is fun to watch is
gonna continue to draw bigger and bigger
crowds I mean there was 10,000 people at
the guard noon on Saturday but he's just
never I don't think he's ever gonna
connect in the same way that an American
would hey one other thing I was told
this over the weekend on Saturday and
that is you know enjoy Brad Stevens in
Boston because he will eventually take
over for Mike sous-chefs key at Duke
what do you think I don't believe no no
I don't I mean yeah I put this I could
tell you 15 different reasons why I
don't think Brad would do it how many
college how many pro coaches can you
name that voluntarily go back to college
I know Dukes difference and Duke special
but you're really since like but you
know did it leaving the Knicks in the in
the 90s and I think Larry Brown did it
in the 80s
since then can you name a coast that
goes voluntarily back to the college
ranks they don't do it I'm known about
it yeah but this is the only this is the
job that he would if you're going to
coach in college this would be he missed
out on Indiana they passed him up at
Indiana who knows why he's done great in
Boston
I just I'm curious if that lifestyle in
the NBA is different or it would be a
difference maker if he went back to
coach at Duke and this is the part of it
I can you know
being around him and his staff I would
be astonished if he he went anywhere
without being you know forced out of
Boston I know what the job at Duke is is
fantastic but people don't leave the pro
lifestyle where you just have to be a
coach where you don't have to deal with
boosters we don't deal with recruiting I
know Duke is dupe you don't have to
recruit in the same way you did at
Butler but you just don't leave us look
Brad Stevens
you know his salary is I think around
like six million dollars per year
something like that eventually as he
keeps winning that's gonna go up uh he's
in his early 40s I'd I'd be I'd be
stunned I mean look look at what he has
right now I mean let's hope he is I just
Jeske like what is he I mean let's
assume he's gone within five years the
Celtics are gonna be really good over
the next five years probably good for
the next ten years because they're their
two stars are in there very early 20s to
two young stars I just I can't see see
Brad Stevens up and leaving that team to
go to Duke or anywhere else thank you
Chris
we appreciate your time three wins away
Dan from you know what's gonna happen
right you know what what's next the bet
a bet
what is our bed what wait wait what
Paulie what's our bet I remember the bet
being if the Celtics go to the NBA
Finals Chris gets to host this show with
you sitting in McLovin chair or in the
back row yeah is that right Chris that's
accurate okay so I don't do anything and
if the Cavs win at the Cavs win
Mannix has to get a buzz cut okay so you
feel pretty good no not at all in fact
I'm running my hands through my hair can
we cut it on air yeah all right that's
it's all about content we appreciate
that Chris I would thank you buddy
that's Chris Mannix Yahoo Sports senior
NBA and boxing writer for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel two
three
nine on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]